my name is Steven sure Dorf and I'm gay
I am queer heterosexual androgynous and
under the transgender umbrella I'm
heterosexual identify myself as a gay
man I'm a heterosexual male I am a
homosexual I'm gay I like men usually
I'm Mickey Kaufman I'm a male to female
transsexual the youngest awareness I had
of gender identity was around three
probably around four or five years old
fourteen-years-old actually in surprise
I remember after seeing the movie Dirty
Dancing when I was like I guess seven or
eight that first dance that Patrick
Swayze and Jennifer Grey have I joined
the Navy mainly to get away from home I
fell in with a group of friends and one
of them pulled me aside one day and said
to me well you're gay and I said what is
gay I've never heard that I never heard
that word before in my dream I was
wearing these big earrings like Diana
earrings they look like drawer handles
they were so big and and pendulous but
they're really beautiful and I woke up
really distraught that I couldn't find
them anywhere and I and I told my mom I
wanted my earrings and I saw the
reaction that I got so I was aware that
this was a transgression of some sorts I
don't think I've ever had a single point
at which I became you know aware of my
sexual orientation I think it's been a
sort of ongoing process as a young adult
I came out as a lesbian that was the
only thing that I could pick I didn't
think that I was homosexual I thought it
was a passing fancy my mom actually
started telling people that you know I
was bisexual and you know sort of outing
me before I was even ready to like you
know have an opportunity I told my
mother I told my father and they were
very supportive of it they didn't
overreact they didn't blow anything out
of proportion they just said looked at
me and said you're my son and I love you
some of my family members would take
their kneels and dig them into my back
and like arch my shoulders and I would
have to like be forced to walk like this
because males walks like that
cheese for my sort of skinny you know
sort of androgynous body your
flat-chested this is like a big word in
seventh grade you're so flat-chested
today boy girl
well I guess I'm never gonna have a
boyfriend if that's what it's all about
the way sexuality shaped my life has
something to do with my profession being
an actor working in cities like this
very closely with a lot of attractive
women feeling the pressure for my
parents to not be gay I think I kind of
turned inward playing music I play the
viola playing the piano
reading I'm now an editor and a writer
having that instability of gender caused
some instability but it also caused the
wisdom and gave my understanding and
dimension that perhaps is unique and and
something I can contribute I don't
define myself on my sexuality it's a
part of who I am but it's not what I am
good evening all of you and welcome to
this session
I'm Andrew Solomon I'll be your
moderator I feel like a game show host
standing here but in any event I'm going
to be the moderator in this discussion
about the origins of orientation about
sexuality about desire about the
relation between science and politics in
these arenas so welcome to all of you
and let me now welcome our panelists
Meredith Jeffers is a clinical
psychologist and professor at Queen's
University in Ontario Canada
her clinical work has focused on
treatment of sexual functioning problems
gender and sexual identity concerns
sexual addiction and atypical sexual
interests Jim Foust is an
internationally known expert in the
neurobiology
of sexual behavior his research examines
have the brains neurochemical and
neuroanatomical systems are organized
for sexual arousal desire pleasure and
inhibition Paul Basie is a behavioral
scientist who focuses on sexuality and
gender from a biosocial perspective his
research includes the evolution of
female homosexual behavior in Japanese
macaques and male same-sex attraction in
humans in Samoa Japan and Canada mark
Breedlove master of neuroscience at
Michigan State University
he has written over a hundred scientific
articles about the role of hormones and
shaping the developing an adult nervous
system including sexual differentiation
of the developing brain welcome so the
opening question that was suggested to
me by the conference organizers was why
did you choose to get involved in the
area of sexuality I've just been on an
assignment in Brazil where I interviewed
the person who is responsible for gay
issues in the city of Rio de Janeiro and
I said to him why do you think there are
many gay tourists going to Rio de
Janeiro and he said have you gone
outside yet with that model in mind I
turned to all of you and say why did you
decide to do research in this arena
Meredith why don't you go for sure
so as an undergraduate I was studying in
Canada at the University of Guelph I was
very interested in neuropsychology and
was taking Bachelor of Science in
psychology really science heavy courses
and I need to bring my GPA up things
were looking kind of grim in my first
year so I many of my friend
told me that I should take a human
sexuality class because it was a really
easy course you could get a really easy
a that way and I had a couple of
experiences in that course that were
sort of aha moments that sort of led me
into into this path so the first one was
being a my prof would quite often show
very explicit erotic images in class and
one of them was a very explicit tight
close-up of woman's vulva and so imagine
you know giant lecture theatre 500
students massive vulva and and around me
were all of these people going you and
most of those people were women and and
I I just I had this moment of shock
looking around this is your body how can
how can you have this kind of response
to this and so that kind of got logged
in the back of my brain and then later
in that course I gave a presentation on
female sexual functioning difficulties
and public speaking has never been my
forte kind of but in any case I walked
away from that experience and I
literally had that sort of epiphany
moment where I thought if I could do
this for the rest of my life I'd be a
really happy woman and so that that set
me on my path are you really happy woman
most of the time I feel pretty lucky to
be able to do something I feel really
passionate about and that every day I
get up and I get to go play in a
laboratory and figure it puzzles that's
wonderful
well I have to say it was my first
orgasm it was a profound event I mean
you think about your first orgasm what
did that feel like what was it what were
you trying to attain what did you not
expect to have happen to you and that
first orgasm really got me wondering why
a why my body had never done this before
B why it felt so good see now I kind of
understood the Iliad in ways that I
didn't before and
and D more importantly where did that
come from did it come from
my penis did it come from my testicles
did it come from my where my body did it
come from and the idea that it came from
my brain even when I was 14 was a kind
of a profound epiphany like you talked
about and I I just had always been
interested in trying to figure that out
so the first thing I did in grad school
was try to figure that out and I got
into the idea that sexual reward where
in the brain was it how is it organized
in the brain and of course I couldn't
study this in people because I couldn't
take their brains out so I had to figure
out a way to model this in a little
critter like a rat and the rest was
history I mean I I just have never
looked back lot told him don't look back
yeah I never looked back
so it's it's been a very rewarding
experience studying sexual reward or my
six research career started when I was a
doctoral student at the University of
Montreal and I had absolutely no funding
and there was no funding in sight so I
had to figure out something that I was
going to be able to do sort of in the
area of Montreal and as luck would have
it the the University of Montreal had a
colony of Japanese monkeys that were
used exclusively for behavioral research
and really only a handful of people had
access access to them strictly for
observational purposes and when I was
thinking about what am I going to do for
my for my doctoral dissertation it was
around the time that the mating season
was starting and there was a lot of
female homosexual behavior in the group
females form these consort pairs couples
and they they mount each other they
solicit each other for sex and this goes
on for days and I thought wow that that
is really interesting because anyone
that knows anything about evolutionary
theory knows that a very basic tenet of
evolutionary theory is that
you organisms are supposed to behave in
ways to maximize their reproductive
success this behavior didn't look like
it was doing that and so I thought this
is something that I could really sink my
teeth into for for a doctoral
dissertation I went the next day I drove
into Montreal because the facility was
outside of Montreal in the country and I
spoke with my supervisor at the time and
told him this is what I want to do I
want to study female homosexual behavior
and Japanese monkeys for my doctoral
dissertation and he said why would you
want to do that it's biologically
irrelevant and he said you should study
reciprocal altruism which I had no
interest in and I very you know very
dejected when drove back to the lab at
this time I was actually living in a
storage room at the lab because I had no
money to to rent an apartment so I was
living with the monkeys I literally I
was living with the monkeys got up the
next day went to see the monkeys and
there were five sexual partners four of
them were female female female
homosexual couples and one was a
heterosexual couple and I thought look
anything that's this common this
widespread in the social group cannot be
biologically irrelevant and I'm going to
study this no matter what the
consequences are right so far things
have worked out well you think with a
last name of Breedlove that would be
inevitable
I insist I'm no more obsessed with sex
than the average person in fact I got
into science because I lived on a farm
until I was 10 years old so so I've
known all my life where fried chicken
comes from I've known the whole process
and and there I was fascinated with
animals some of my earliest memories are
I would submit I was really interested
in this spider that had made a web in
one corner of the house and I was and
you know it's really interesting when an
insect would fall there would dash out
from hiding the dash
and so I've been you know really
interested in that and that sort of
metaphor of animals as machines and so
how do you understand how their behavior
comes about and and and I actually
didn't so when I went to graduate school
it was to try to understand this
relationship between the nervous system
and behavior and I wasn't actually
interested in hormones my first year in
graduate school but you know I took some
courses and as I learned more about
hormones I realized that there was an
incredible opportunity here you inject
an animal with a hormone and six hours
later there's a reliable change in the
behavior well if you want to understand
how the nervous system controls behavior
then all you have to do is trace the
hormone right where does it go what is
it to what sort of changes is it make
you you'd think and so that makes it
sound like a simple problem right so
here I am
you know 30-some years later and I don't
have a completely satisfactory answer
but and and so and so that's really how
I got into into hormones and then in
terms of sex differences it's even more
compelling you you you take an animal on
the day of birth you inject it with a
hormone and a long time later in that
animal's life time what we would
consider decades later there's a
reliable change in the behavior because
the animal got that hormone you know
that one time early in life and so all
you have to do is trace the hormones and
and that's enough that's that's a
reasonable quest and and I would say I'm
delighted with how it's all come out of
me I feel very lucky I'm you know I'm
from a blue-collar family obviously and
so I think it's so wonderful I get to
study this stuff that I'm interested in
well I think there are an enormous
number of questions to be drawn from all
of your work and the various ways in
which it weaves together but it seems to
me central to consider the question of
how we've moved from the definition of
sex as primarily the biological
imperative through which the species is
perpetuated and what the philosophical
shifts have been and how the scientific
and philosophical chefs have been
entwined as we've come in to acknowledge
that sexuality is not simply a means for
producing offspring there have been huge
shifts in those areas there have been
huge shifts in the whole way that we
think about desire that there have been
whole shifts in this question of the
ideology of sexuality and what it is
that forms these inclinations and wishes
does anyone want to tackle that question
so if I can just jump in I mean I think
it's been instructive in the I was
taught that rats were little automatons
that there were Nike commercials you put
them together and they'll just do it
that there's no learning there's no
social system that might affect their
sexual behavior because they're way
lower on the totem pole then you know
primates are and they have a social
structure and then humans are like a
Monty Python skit something completely
different right and it occurred to me
that that wasn't true that there were
individual differences and what rats did
some rats wouldn't do it at all some
would do it a lot
why were these differences there if the
biological drive was the most important
thing right and it got me to thinking
that well the brain didn't evolve
necessarily for reproduction it evolved
to eat to interact with the outside
world and part of the outside world is
ever-changing and it requires a brain
that can kind of learn and that got me
into thinking well if it's instinctual
to learn what a rat's learn about sex
should they learn anything
turns out they learn an enormous amount
to the point that I can take a rat put a
little road and jacket on it for its
first sexual experience and get that rat
to not be able to have sex without
having that jacket on which means that
the jacket has become a fetish now we
think of fetish behavior in rats we
think my god if they can do it imagine
what we can do the jackets will be
available for purchase
and I think there's been a reciprocal
sort of cross-pollination between the
animal work and the human work because
at the same time that the the people
doing the animal work I've come to
understand or see the importance of
experience I think the people in the in
working in human behavior have come to
see that nature has some influence as
well and that it's not just learning
yeah absolutely I mean I work in Samoa
which is a small island in the South
Pacific I began that research program
with my colleague Nancy Bartlett who's
in in the audience tonight and I mean
there it's so inch I'm gay so as a gay
man going going to Samoa to do the
research there you know in scientific
lingo we would refer to me as an
underfill ik male so I'm a male who's
sexually attracted to adult males so you
can go anywhere in the world and find
other andrew philic males there are
Andrew philic males in Samoa and this is
sort of getting out even here on this
there are some there's two by my count
so this is sort of getting at your whole
point of how important is socialization
I think that the the the the sexual
attraction and the sexual arousal
that's biological but then it's
elaborated on culturally so for example
I can go I can go to someone there are
Andrew philic males there and but there
are no there are no gay men none
whatsoever
and and you can you can talk to these a
trophy like males who in some other call
15a which means in the manner of a woman
and so they they present publicly
typically in a very feminine manner
they'd be what in this culture we refer
to as effeminate males or in many cases
even transgendered males and they're
exclusively sexually attracted to
masculine males pretty much just like
all Andrew philic males are attracted to
masculinity masculine
it's for the most part but they don't
self-identify as gay so that identity
part is socialized when when they were
when they were growing up gay was not an
identity category that they could draw
upon to construct who they are just like
when I was growing up I didn't say mom
dad sit down I have something very
important to tell you I'm a 15 a because
it wasn't an identity category that I
could draw up on so there's there's
there's biological predispositions but
they're elaborated on culturally and
those cultural elaborations have all
sorts of implications in terms of how
you self present in public what others
expect from you in here in this culture
I'm I'm expected to behave in a
masculine manner in most places it's
demanded of you in Samoa that's not the
case you're expected to be feminine and
you're expected have certain roles
within the family certain obligations in
terms of taking care of your nieces and
nephews so biology and culture are both
important I think the very diversity of
this panel and the diversity of work
that's being done by all of you
reflects a growing understanding that
sexuality is over determined that in
popular culture there is a tendency over
and over again to say you know our
people gay because of a gay gene can we
find it then we'll know why all gay
people are gay are women who are aroused
by watching chimpanzees and for example
that being a piece of the work you do
bonobos rather is there a kind of
explanation for that that comes from the
way that they've been socialized can we
then understand all female arousal as
being based entirely on the way that
people are socialized what happens to
them early on the idea that in fact
there are these many different factors
that are coming together far more
factors that I think we're probably able
to name at this point seems to be one
that's gaining currency and it seems to
be one that you're all working toward
it's one of the things that I've been
sharing and reading the papers that
you've all written that none of you seem
to be saying I figured it out it's all
about this but rather to be saying this
the component of a much larger and more
complex process does that ring true the
others that were including you for your
work with absolutely so um the research
I've done primarily to this point is a
sexual psyche of physiology and when I
was a graduate students when I started
doing the research that involved the the
bonobo the bonobos study where we had
women watching an array of sexual
stimuli including a bonobo film and they
showed genital responses to this and and
this study was initially conducted to
demonstrate that really what we were
seeing with other studies were straight
women we're lesbian women we're not
differentiating between gay straight or
lesbian couples having sex but it wasn't
necessarily that women all women were
bisexual which was one sort of really
clumsy interpretation of those data was
that maybe there's something you know
there's a feature to all of these films
that it's common which is sexual
activity so that's why we did that the
bonobos studied to demonstrate that just
showing any kind of sexual activity
might generate this physiological
response without women necessarily
saying that they were feeling aroused
but what this required to be able to
begin to interpret these data was just
for me was a paradigm shift so to you
know all of the the the learning that
had come before for me as so this was I
was a master student at this time trying
to interpret these data where what I saw
very assertive male interpretations of
sexual and male models of female
sexuality and and here we had these
results that completely flew in the face
of everything that we understood or at
least we assumed that we understood
about how things should shake out with
arousal and and sexual orientation and
so it's been a process of sort of
rebuilding how we understand female
sexuality what are the the gender
differences and how what are the
implications for understanding for
example sexual orientation
I mean I'm also interested in other
questions but sexual functioning but in
particular what does it mean for
orientation I think your question really
at the base of your question is really
what is sexual orientation so is sexual
orientation genital blood-flow genital
arousal is sexual orientation your
identity what you what you label
yourself
sexual-orientation who you have sex with
your behavior it or is sexual
orientation who you're attracted to what
your sexual fantasies are what your
feelings are I think most sex
researchers would say sexual orientation
hope I'm not speaking out of turn here
but I think most sex researchers would
say what you're thinking about when
you're masturbating is a pretty good
Minoo take on what your what your sexual
orientation is all about and then once
we once we decide ok that's how we're
going to measure sexual orientation I
think that we have to think about it in
terms of is it just about being
attracted to male bodied individuals for
a masculine or female bodied individuals
who are feminine or is there an engage
component is there an activity component
is there a species component to
zoophiles have an orientation that is
distinct it seems very impoverished to
me to describe a zoo a phial someone
who's preferentially attracted to say
horses as being heterosexual or
homosexual that doesn't at all seem to
get at what their sexual orientation is
so there's all these sort of layers to
sexual orientation most of us are
attracted to adults but it's so common
that we don't even think of that as
being part of our our orientations and I
think oh if I can just interject I think
also we have this massive cortex that
likes to give us single terms that
easily define us both to ourselves and
to others so being gay or straight or bi
right as opposed to being maybe mostly
gay maybe mostly straight maybe
sometimes by sometimes not and to the
extent that there's a fluidity which I
don't like that word but if there is a
fluidity to to the to the definition
then it's going to create a conflict if
you behave in a way that's different
from what you think you are or from what
other people think you are or should be
right but I I think to come back partly
to what you said middles to it you said
there is a sense that these categories
are constantly being redefined so we sit
here and in a way there's almost a comic
element to suggesting that we would
equate our sexual identities with those
are people who are primarily attracted
to horses and yet gave sexual identity
as we now know it is a relatively recent
invention I mean I'm often struck by the
idea that to be gay not very long ago
was an illness and a sin and a crime and
now it's an identity which was broadly
accepted and openly discussed on stages
and lower Manhattan and I think that the
way in which that shift has taken place
is very dramatic and I think it's very
difficult to predict what other shifts
may take place and what behaviors and
practices that now seem bizarre and
aberrant even to those of us who
consider ourselves enlightened will seem
less bizarre and aberrant as we come up
with a clearer and more profound
understanding of what their point of
origin is where they come from I'm often
struck by the smug moralizing that goes
on among people who are not pedophiles
in relation to be flu are pedophiles I
am NOT myself a pedophile but I know
that I am someone who has various
desires that when at one point had been
illegal and criminalized and then it
would have been a terrible struggle for
me not to act on them or acknowledge
them to myself at the time and they
would have been crimes and when they
would have landed me in prison I'm
relieved that those desires are no
longer criminalized I do believe that
it's terribly important to protect
children and to protect animals who are
not able to be consensual sexual
partners I understand what the
philosophical issues are I still think
that these definitions of what
constitutes acceptable sexuality and
what constitutes unacceptable sexuality
while they are changing are no more
profoundly true and fully resolved now
than they were for the Victorians does
that ring true to any of you I mean
clearly such ideas are still in flux and
and and the the public's ideas about
them are still in flux and energy
quite quickly so I mean it might be hard
to keep track of this in Manhattan where
things are you know perhaps not
representative the entire country but I
was really like it's possible I was
really struck by the the Pew surveys
that that found the the statistic that
stayed with me was that 66 percent of
American Catholics thought that
homosexuality should be accepted well
that's I mean that's really astounding
that's a very fast change it's not just
it's not just the you know social change
through funerals is the the thing that
we talked about where the people that
are most homophobic are most likely our
oldest and therefore most likely to die
I mean it's so queerly things are
changing fast and in its and and I think
the the sort of research showing that
there are in fact several different
influences on sexual orientation I think
that's for many Americans at least that
seems to be helping them to accept this
idea that homosexuality is is you know
it's not something that has to be
treated in the ways you spoke of just a
few years ago I think that there's
there's a sort of sadness embedded in
those truths that you shared which is
that much of America appears now to have
accepted the validity of being
homosexual being gay whatever one wants
to call it alternative sexual identities
I think is one phrase think it's banding
around but in part around this question
of choice if you've chosen to be gay
then you don't deserve any protections
and if there was nothing you could ever
do about it because hormonal events in
the womb or some gene or an anomalous
construction for hypothalamus are
causing this to be the case then you
deserve more tolerance and it seems to
me that that's a very narrow idea of
Tolerance the idea that you only
tolerate what is inevitable and that you
don't tolerate the decisions and choices
that people make I mean in all of your
work you are variously looking at
hormones you're looking at various kinds
of arousal you're looking at social
conditions you're looking at these many
different things what is your sense of
how much of a role choice plays in
in sexual orientation and identity and
what is your sense of the way in which
in which biology and biology and choice
and experience headed how do they only
interact in your various work well yeah
that's a that's a heavy question yeah
that's probably the heaviest question
because nothing happens in a vacuum and
things are not static when you are born
in fact when you're in utero your brain
is developing when you're born your
brain continues to develop when you're
engaging in you know in in in gender
appropriate versus inappropriate
behavior or whatever the hell that means
your brain is still developing and
you're getting a sense of who you are on
the basis of being bad me or good me
being accepted me or unaccepted me and
you you you grow in this social
circumstance where you learn the rules
of engagement you learn how to get what
you need how to get what you don't need
and ultimately puberty hits and all of
this then becomes kind of concentrated
in terms of blood flow and your genitals
and what is directing that blood flow
are you directing that blood flow or is
it being directed by things in the
external world that when you see them
you end up with the Wayne's World shall
we happening right and I mean I say that
for both men and women so the question
then is not so much is there a static
event that happens but is there a
process that happens to the point that
once you're there there is no choice
just as there's no choice that you're
not gonna eat a cockroach that you've
stepped on there is no choice you know
what you like you're not necessarily in
knowledge of what you don't like but
once you're there you're there and then
you get to this embellishing that Paul
well I think it's about I think as well
you have to say you have to ask her
this choice question you have to say can
you are you choosing who you're
attracted to I don't think there are
there is any good data that demonstrates
that we choose to be attracted to male
bodied individuals or female bodied
individuals can we choose to act on
those feelings well yeah we can
we can choose to act on them because
there are some people who choose not to
act on them and and submit themselves to
reparative therapy and try to try to try
to not think those thoughts and and act
on them can we choose our identities can
we choose can we be sexually attracted
to adult males but choose not to
identify as gay choose rather to
identify as straight and be on the
down-low yeah absolutely so we can make
choices about behaviors we can make
choices about identity but we don't we
don't make choices about who were
attracted to and what arouses us
generally I I would agree with that I
wonder whether you would agree with it
as being as true for women as it is for
men that being your Lena well just to
riff off of what Paul is said I think
that it's a process of discovery and I
absolutely agree that it's this isn't a
choice and if I've learned anything and
the research that I've done so far is
that equate Anor orientation with
genital responding it's just kind of
silly it doesn't make any sense it
doesn't fit with what the what the data
are saying and and certainly you know
women are not making choices to become
aroused to you for example bonobo
stimuli so a it just doesn't fit it
doesn't fit with with that model yeah
one of the things that I I get concerned
about with you know we brought up this
idea of fluidity of female sexuality you
know fluidity really implies that
there's sort of this you know women have
this capacity to sort of be either same
or opposite sex attracted and you know
we're only beginning to understand what
the factors are that contribute to the
expression of semen opposite sex
attractions and sexual relationships but
within that is an implication that so
again talking about Reppert of therapy
that there is more flexibility in a
female sexual system that you can then
volitionally say well if I have the
fluidity to be you know
same-sex attracted why can that not be
channeled into opposite sex attraction
and I think that that's a really
dangerous path I don't believe that
that's necessarily the case right I mean
I've been very interested I've been
doing a lot of work on people who are
trans it's a chapter in a book I'm
reading now which is about transgender
children and their families and the
question there is a much more vital one
I think in serious academic circles the
question of preparator therapy than it
is for gay people I mean the idea for
parity of therapy for gay people is now
largely relegated to a kind of
right-wing extremism and religious
fundamentalism there are still a great
many people kensic are leading among
them but others who follow in that model
who say that being transgender is
actually in effect that it's ridiculous
I mean he said at one point the idea of
accommodating these children because the
child comes home and says mommy I'm
really a girl when you can see perfectly
well the child as a boy he said I mean
it's like he said you know it's like if
this child who's black came home and
said I'm really white you wouldn't start
bleaching their skin you would try to
teach them to be comfortable with who
they there's all of this conversation
that goes on about Anatomy is destiny
and so on and so forth you're looking at
the arguments that have gone on around
whether people who are crowns should be
cured or not it's hard not to see I mean
it's impossible not to see parallels to
the way the people who are gay have been
treated to the city the gender shock
issues the ways in which various kinds
of therapies were used to convert gay
people it's difficult though reading all
of the literature to decide whether the
situations are the same or whether
they're different and I wonder what
everyone's take would be on gender
identity as opposed to sexuality and how
they're fixed or how in terms of gender
identity maybe one difference is you
know that if if a child decides that
they should be the other sex and if that
continues to unfold you know in in that
pathway then there's a question of
having surgery at some point at cetera
and and so and it's difficult to know I
mean at what point does a child actually
know their own mind and it's for the
same reason we don't let them vote if we
don't let them you know make other
decisions about about
medical treatment then there's this this
tough situation I think therapists are
in do you know to what extent do you you
know it help the child that down this
pathway or if you can't persuade the
child to be happy with the anatomy
they've got aren't you aren't you doing
the child a favor and and then you know
so how far do you go to try to persuade
the child to be happy with the end with
the but the sex they were born into is I
mean I think it's a tough call always
not persuade them in a punitive way I
mean my I think I think Ken Zucker is
often vilified and unfairly I'd my
understanding of of what Ken is trying
to do is make these kids more
comfortable with the bodies that they
have and the reason he's doing that is
because and Meredith might be able to
articulate this more clearly than I can
but what what what I think ken is trying
to do is make them more comfortable with
the bodies they have because it's
difficult at that age to identify is
that child really going to grow up to be
trans because the vast majority of those
children that are diagnosed with
something called gender identity
disorder which is sort of like a
transsexualism or indicator of
transsexualism and childhood the vast
majority of those kids will not grow up
to be trans so Ken I think what he's
trying to do is help them be comfortable
growing up to be gay men and lesbian
women is that fair absolutely I mean the
data on which these that this hypothesis
is based is not as rich as we'd like it
to be there's one longitudinal study
that Richard Greene had done following
boys with gender atypical behavior and
about 70% of those grew up to be gay men
still a substantial percentage you're
identifying his trance but yeah I think
that's fair
and you have to feel like it's a better
outcome if when they reach puberty they
find that they're perfectly happy to
have a penis right that that they don't
I mean that that's that's you know a
better outcome for the child
and once this once these kids hit
adolescence it just should be said that
ken is completely on board with
supporting them in terms of their
choices because he recognizes if if
there's a teen that's identifying as
trans that that is that all the data
suggests that that is very unlikely to
change as opposed to someone who is
prepubescent that's right
I mean IRA struck one of the children
whom I interviewed in doing that work
who was incredibly clear about the fact
that she was a girl she had been born
with this male body she didn't know why
but she was a girl and she was just so
and it was all incredibly clear and
straightforward and her family had been
immensely supportive in what appeared to
be in this instance a very positive way
and she was living as a girl and I mean
the issue of course and I want to get
off onto this tangent but it going on
puberty blockers and not developing
secondary sexual characteristics of the
other gender for people who will be
trapped there are advantages to
identifying in that way early on and not
having to go through a much more
difficult transition after puberty so
the issues are complicated but in any
event we had this long conversation and
then I said just kind of whimsically and
I said and I said chump tell me where do
you think you'll live when you grow up
and she said I think that I'll live in a
tree house in California with hair long
enough to reach Arizona well okay I mean
the fantasy life the real life was an
authentic revelation what's obviously
transient these things can be it can be
very complicated I'm concerned about the
work that everyone is involved with
which is about really the etiology of
sexual orientation because I'm concerned
that in almost every instance in which
the origins of any form of difference
have been identified the knowledge of
those origins has been used in many
instances in attempts to eliminate that
identity so there was a story I was told
which I found which was very sad to me
that there's this work that I think all
of you were
are well aware uh that shown that women
who have multiple sons the likelihood of
one of those of a son being gay
increases correct me if I'm not
lyrically but increases the more sons
that the mother has with each additional
son but likelihood that child will be
gay increases by substantial presented
so I and my husband had children through
surrogacy and I got quite interested in
the area of surrogacy and talked to a
lot of surrogates and one of the people
I talked to said that she had had she
had been a surrogate six times now when
you're looking for surrogates one of the
things when I look for someone who was
both physically and emotionally prepared
to deal with the challenges that are
attached to being a surrogate to
relinquishing a child whom you've
carried and so on and so forth so
surrogates in general the city's popular
wisdom has been it's better if you can
to get someone who has some experience
this woman described having someone who
had actually gone quite a long way
toward working with her who then read
those statistics and said you've
actually been a surrogate you've
produced three boys that means that if
we conceive a male child whom you carry
the likelihood that that child will end
up being gay is much higher we're not
going to work with you we want to find
someone fresh and new and it was an
indication in that specific and narrow
situation which is not one that will be
reproduced constantly but if the ways in
which people once they have an idea oh
it has to do with androgen levels in
utero you know can we test those
androgen levels and can we abort the
fetus if we discover the androgen level
is too high oh it's a genetic question
how can we find the gene so how does the
work that you do which is essentially I
think about at some grand level not only
identifying but also supporting the
diversity of sexual experience how do
you deal with the implications it may
have in narrowing those very
possibilities I think this gets at a
great divide between the people doing
the research and the public that's
hearing about it that gets out the idea
you talk about about how over determined
human behavior is certainly sexual
orientation so um you know we have to
work so hard just to find any influence
because there are so many different
influences and you can only
find an influence by isolating one
little factor at a time and so and so
for those folks I can tell you the
statistics are that you have to have
something like twelve older brothers
just to have a 50/50 chance of being gay
right but but but people don't
understand that you can never a point to
a given individual and say this
individual is gay because they have an
older brother because of course there
are lots of most men out there with
seven older brothers are straight and
and so we have to sift through the
statistics to find the fact that that
influence is there has been very well
replicated and it's and it's an entering
statistic in that older brothers
increase the chance of a boy being gay
but only if that boy is right-handed if
the boy is left-handed then this
influence whatever it is doesn't come
into play and and and then when you
realize you know seven older brothers
and still most likely to be that it
would be silly even if you thought it
was okay to try to stop people from
growing up to be gay it would be crazy
to go at it that way because it's such a
tiny little influence that you have to
use statistics to find it and so it's
not that it lets you know why this
individual is gay on the other hand when
when you look at the statistics and find
that effect there every time you have to
ask yourself well how can that be that's
something that happened not just before
this person was born but before they
were conceived change the probability of
what their sexual orientation would be
you know how do you how do you square
that with the idea of choice right that
they I mean who chose to have four older
brothers right that's that's a that's a
strange idea I was just gonna say plus
then you have the baffling array of
possible genes there's not gonna be one
gene there's gonna be multiples which
act on each other which act on each
other during these developmental epochs
that I discussed earlier which you know
at the end point I don't think you're
ever going to be able to make a
prediction from one of those and I would
guarantee you if in some draconian
future you could identify many of these
and knock them all out probably you'd
kill the fetus so the question then is
well you know is this then a trait is
homosexuality a trait for survivability
and if it is I guarantee you the people
doing the killing are going to be ousted
very quickly because you want that in
the population you don't not want it in
the population but wanting it in the
population is exactly right can I ask
you about what role do you think that
difficult to pronounce
15 a 15 a play in Samoa and why do you
think there's a cultural value on that
role in that society in a way that there
isn't in some others well a lot of my
research in Samoa is really focused on
okay if there are genes for same-sex
sexual attraction in males which it
looks like there are we might not be
able to identify what the specific genes
are but various bits and pieces of
information all point to the direction
that there's there's a genetic basis for
this how are these genes maintained in a
population if these individuals for the
most part at least in Samoa are not
reproducing so one of the one of the
theories is that well you might not
reproduce yourself directly but you
might help your close relatives like
brothers and sisters reproduce by taking
care of their children for them and
therefore allowing them to produce more
children with whom you share genes and
therefore you're passing on genes
indirectly in the population through
your nieces and nephews so the research
we've been doing in Samoa has shown over
and over and over again that fatha
Feeney
these males who are sexually attracted
to adult masculine men are more
avuncular they're more uncle like in
terms of their tendencies than women and
men so they they clearly no matter how
many times we attempt to test this and
test it in different ways and falsify it
we never can this effect is real 15 a
arm or uncle like than men and women in
Samoa and this is consistent with this
kin selection hypothesis for male
same-sex sexual attraction why does that
exist
well were
we're working on it but one of the one
of the reasons it might exist is on a
very proximate social level is that
there is there is an expectation among
Samoans that 15-a play an important role
in terms of and this is something you
hear over and over again people in some
ways say bringing the family together
they get there the glue that holds the
family together they bring the family
together so when you're when you when
you grow when you're a little fluffy a
growing up in that social system and
this is these are the messages that are
being fed to you this is now your social
role this is what's expected by your
community in your family and just
getting back to this whole idea of the
science and and it being scary and
having these negative potential negative
effects on society just just the the the
of Uncle arity research we've been doing
in Samoa has been nothing but a good
news story because there's all of these
you you think about conservative
Christian groups in North America saying
homosexuals are destructive to the
family well all of the research in Samoa
shows the exact opposite there they're
integral in terms of bringing the family
together making the family stronger
raising the nieces and nephews and
that's what I'm fighting a sexual outlet
for adolescent heterosexual males that's
sometimes that's the case yes I didn't
by any means which is a guest that the
sign should be stopped
to achieve a social agenda I'm only
struck by the irony that exists
certainly exists in certain areas of
disability like deafness that just as
the idea of deafness has gained
political ascendancy and deaf people
have been more broadly socially accepted
the advent of the cochlear implant has
meant effectively that there are fewer
and fewer deaf people and that there is
sometimes I kind of strange crossing
between scientific insight
and the cures that it may represent
which are in a future draconian or
otherwise that's very distant in this
arena but the nonetheless is not
unimaginable and have could have its
roots in the kind of work that we're
discussing here that there can be a
dramatic relationship between at the
political acceptance and liberation and
the scientific research which then
diminishes the population for whom those
achievements have been arrived at it
would it would never be a reason not to
make the scientific progress and
scientific progress hopefully would
enable choice rather than cause that
closing down but they are still they're
complicated questions that are at the
margins I think of a lot of what all of
you are doing Meredith when we were back
in the green room you said that your
newest research and given you some very
surprising results that altered in a way
the previous work you've done sure
okay well I'll give a little bit of a
preamble so some of the research that I
had conducted as a graduate student then
as a postdoctoral fellow is the one
that's been sort of most publicized
looking at women's sexual response in
the laboratory and responsiveness to
male and female sexual stimuli and sort
of the really surprising thing is that
what we'd initially found is that women
regardless of whether they are same or
opposite sex attracted we're showing
significant genital responses to both
male and female sexual stimuli that was
sort of the initial study that I did as
a part of my doctoral thesis and then I
did a postdoctoral study which suggested
that women who were same-sex attracted
sort of rarified the stimuli previously
we were using films of couples and and
there's so much going on and that we
stripped it down to just solitary women
and men and in using these films of
solitary women and men demonstrated that
women who identified as lesbian who were
same-sex attracted were actually
starting to differentiate in their
arousal patterns so they were becoming a
little bit more aroused to to the women
than to to the men but the the straight
women were not differentiating by gender
and so we've taken this a little bit
further and so I
two years ago started a assistant
professor position at Queen's University
in Kingston and have done a study with
primarily by sexually attracted to women
and rolled them into this sort of data
analysis is ongoing study of trying to
figure out what's going on you know this
this pattern of arousal just doesn't fit
with again as I said sort of this male
model of how things are supposed to work
if you're turned on by these people if
you're choosing to have sex with these
people well you should become only
sexually aroused by those people so know
why both and as we've rolled this data
together I've looked at these patterns
of arousal to two women and two men in
women who report no sexual attraction to
women at all
so exclusively heterosexual women and
then two women with varying degrees of
same-sex attraction and so in in in this
research we use commonly used Kinsey
scales to sort of have people quantify
the degree of their same and opposite
sex attraction so a Kinsey zero is a
person whose exclusively heterosexual
Kinsey one is an individual who says I'm
predominantly heterosexual but I
definitely have some same-sex feelings
and so on it goes up to two sixes and
what we've what I found is that the the
the people who are the big puzzle are
the heterosexual women and all of the
other women with some degrees of
same-sex attraction what's really
fascinating is sort of as you go up that
Kinsey scale from you know just a little
bit same-sex attracted to exclusively
same-sex attracted this arousal to women
becomes more and more and more
differentiated from that of men but the
women who do not differentiate at all
are the heterosexual the exclusively
heterosexual women and so this is very
very recent data it's not even published
yet we're in the process of writing this
up but we've we've replicated this both
using audio-visual sexual stimuli as
well as audio stimuli so stories that
are describing sexual interactions and
so they the question becomes what is
going on with heterosexual women instead
of you know responding to some of these
questions about you know studying sexual
orientation we're not just studying
sexual minorities we're studying
orientation as a phenomenon itself
and I never thought I'd be in this
position of saying wait straight women
are the ones that we really don't get
this doesn't fit with the model but
again you know maybe the model doesn't
work we need to re-examine all of our
previous assumptions that led us to
developing this model of what the
relationship is between patterns of
sexual attraction arousal and
orientation and come up with a new one
that fits the data so that's what I'm
trying to do and the part of your
previous work then I found most
interesting was the and again correct me
if I'm not characterizing it correctly
but that you were using both physical
instruments to measure people's arousal
and giving people some sort of device
through which they could give a
self-report arousal yes and that there
was frequently an enormous gap that's
what people thought they were aroused by
and what they were actually aroused by
yeah I thought that in terms of the
social conditioning questions we've been
discussing was fast to me what what is
your spin on that why does that happen
well great question don't have an easy
answer this is a very well replicated
gender difference that that for men the
agreement between their physiological
responses as well as their their self
report of how turned on or arouse that
they feel the the correlation or
agreement is very strong and and for
women they there is a significant
correlation between those but it tends
to be much smaller the effect is is much
smaller it mean it's really striking
when you see in a study like with the
bonobo film where women are having this
what seems like a very automatic
physiological response this young
vaginal vasocongestion the onset of
which is seconds from the onset of the
film itself and the women are reporting
that they're not feeling turned on at
all same as you know watching a lesbian
woman watching gay male porn and saying
she's not turned on at all and yet you
know she's exhibiting this very strong
physiological response and I mean the
simplest answer is that psychological
experience of sexual arousal is just not
dependent solely on this this
physiological experience of genital
vasocongestion you know some have have
speculated that this has something to do
with genital Anatomy women's general not
to be much more Hidden penis far more
obvious
giving off all kinds of obvious cues of
arousal but this pattern of disconnect
in emotional responding is not exclusive
to sexual responding so you know emotion
theorists who are looking at other
aspects of for example anxiety and so on
have noticed these kinds of gender
differences so I think we may be
observing a phenomenon that's not
exclusive to sexuality I'm very
interested in in the larger question and
we're looking at models from all of you
variously of sexuality which is based on
social circumstance based on hormones
based on the leather jackets on rats
based on a society that accepts people
but I am also interested in whether what
the scientific experiences or what the
scientific language is to describe the
aspect of sexuality that's founded in
love or indeed the aspect of love that's
founded in sexuality because while I
think it seems almost certainly not to
be the case at least for most people
that how they're parented determines who
they desire sexual what gender they
desire sexually there's a lot of
evidence that early experience
predisposes you to reproduce certain
kinds of emotional relationships that
abuse children often end up finding
loved in situations in which that abuse
is replicated and so on and so forth and
I just wonder I know it's a pain of
sexuality was already sort of a mushy
topic and love makes it worse but weird
is where the perceptions of love fit
into the work that each of you is doing
well one thing that love sometimes gets
I don't know shall we say reduced to is
bonding now there are many kinds of
bonding I mean we bond to our cats we
bond to our partners who bond to our
parents we bond to our children but
there is a common brain system that in
but actually activates that bonding and
all of those circumstances whether it's
a romantic bonding or the attachment
that a couple feels thirty years after
they were married
they're the work of oxytocin in the
brain is absolutely critical for all of
those bonding experiences right
including maternal bonding clearly and
and what what's striking is as you read
the scientific literature on maternal
bonding if you know something about the
bonding of you know say prairie voles to
each other after their first magnificent
sexual experience they all involve the
activation of oxytocin the same areas of
the brain clearly there is functioning
in the cortex that's identifying your
sex partners being different from your
child and your child is being different
from your sex partner from your cat I
hope but you the the fact that you're
getting the same areas of the brain
activated by this particular and
activating this particular
neurotransmitter led us to start looking
at this function in rats because rats
are allegedly polygamous so they want to
bales want to spread the genes Lauren
why didn't the pool females want to
spread their genes far and wide the pool
so females will accept you if you're a
swizzle stick if you're a rat if you're
maybe something else better etc so we
started to look at this because as it
turns out a very simple conditioning
procedure where the exposure to their
first sex partner who's wearing an
almond odor
now almond is neutral these animals
don't care about this but if you do this
and they learn that their first sex
partner is an almond scented partner you
give them a choice between an almond
scented unscented partner and they will
copulate preferentially with the almond
scented partner so why would a
polygamous animal do that that's dumb
unless unless and this this gets to your
idea of kind of rethinking these old
tired ideas about the way things work
unless maybe the brain is neither
polygamists or monogamous it's really
opportunistic and whatever you learn in
these early critical periods of sexual
behavior development your early
experiences with reward are telling you
that that reward comes in this almond
package well it turns out if you give
them the almond odor you activate
oxytocin in the brains but only in the
ones that had their initial sexual
experience
with the almond scent a partner and I
think that's a metaphor for what happens
in humans because there are facial
structures there's hair color
there's the astraying differences size
whatever it might be that we are each
individually uniquely attracted to that
activate this bonding process very very
Freudian idea and that idea that that
early experience is that richly
determinative of who one is capable of
loving who one will be drawn to I mean
it's I I I kind of like Freud but it's
not a very fashionable perspective but
maybe it's one that needs to come back
you know Keith Kendrick in England did a
study with sheep and goats and he cross
fostered them or gave them their regular
sheep or goat moms and it turns out that
the males that were cross fostered
preferred and in fact uniquely preferred
to have sex with the a sexually
receptive partner that was of the cross
fostered species so if you're a male
goat and you were cross foster with a
sheep mom you have a choice you can have
sex with a female sheep or a female goat
guess what you're a male goat cross
flesh of the sheep mom you go after the
sheep female hmm so why is that and is
it mom or is it just the reward that's
associated with being nursed by mom
being comforted by mom being taken care
of and it it turns out it's probably
related to the activation of the reward
pathways in the brain that then activate
the oxytocin so when you see your loved
one you say that gives me reward
I want that come to me cuddle with me
all of that is reward opioid activation
in your brain activating dopamine and
oxytocin but that study does open up the
idea that early childhood experience in
the nature of the nurse friend who
received could in fact be the
determining factor in sexual orientation
back to our theme of the evening what do
you make well but but but people have
looked for those things including
looking for studying the search you know
I talked earlier about how we have to
work so hard to find any evidence of an
influence so people worked hard to find
whether you know having a cold distant
father makes one more likely to grow up
to be gay etc and
and and you know right here those things
you know there's always the chicken and
egg problem or the cause and effect you
know is is the father called a distant
because because I mean is a child gay
because the father is called distant or
as a father cold and distant because he
sees his child growing up to be gay but
even so you'd think that it would be
there but people look really hard for
those courts and you just don't find
them so so in terms of I mean of course
it matters in terms of you know are you
attracted to do blondes or people in
flashy cars I suppose or you know all
those Disney movies I'm sure they're you
know they're pushing that image out
there all the time about not too flashy
cars but but and so I'm sure those
things matter but in terms of basic
sexual orientation you know the data
just don't seem to bear that out but in
a way then that brings us to another
question that's I think very much
implied by Oliver we've been discussing
which is that is obviously easier to do
a lot of controlled experiments on
sexuality by cross-fostering goats and
sheep than by cross-fostering human
beings but he is human sexuality I mean
almost all of you you have well not
including the bonobos but you all done
work which has in various ways involved
animals how much can we generalize from
what we determined to be true of the
sexuality of other animals to human
beings and how much are human beings are
completely distinct every species is a
unique species every every species has a
unique evolutionary history so we have
to I've studied Japanese macaques and
I've studied humans as well we have to
be very careful about you know
generalizing from one species to the
next because every species is unique but
I can take what I've learned in Japanese
macaques and use that as a model for how
sexuality might be potentially organized
or potentially developed in humans it
doesn't mean that that's the case but I
can use the Japanese monkeys as
inspiration for how I might think about
sexuality in humans and testing
hypotheses about sexuality in humans
well why don't you is someone who's
particularly focused really on to
specific populations what are the ways
in which what you've learned from the
macaques is relevant to what you've
learned about the Samoans and what are
the ways in which it it is if their
connection or they just two separate
things you happen to be doing that's a
question I get asked all the time and
there it's there there isn't an easy
answer you know a easy soundbite the the
the female homosexual behavior in the
Japanese macaques for a long time those
kinds of same-sex sexual behaviors and
animals have been characterized by
biologists as being what's called socio
sexual behaviors so these are behaviors
that are superficially they look sexual
but the argument has always been but the
animals aren't doing it because it's
sexual they're doing it to facilitate
some sort of adaptive social goal like
alliance formation or dominance
demonstration or reconciliation in other
words it's an adaptive behavior to bring
about some functional social goal it
doesn't look at all like that's what's
happening in Japanese macaques which is
which was a bit of a shocker for me as a
doctoral student because I realized wow
I'm not the animals haven't read the
same evolutionary textbooks why bread
they're not doing what they're supposed
to be doing and suddenly my job is a lot
more complicated I'm no longer standing
on the shoulders of giants I have to
completely rethink my haha why they're
doing what they're doing what models I'm
using it doesn't look like it's an
adaptation so I've you know it's been
almost 20 years now that I've been
studying the Japanese macaques and I
think what's happening is that there are
very in the populations that I work in
there are very high levels of female
male mounting so this non conceptive or
non reproductive heterosexual behavior
so it's very common during a
heterosexual interaction that a male for
example might get tired because they're
they're multiple
now they mount each other multiple times
before an ejaculation takes place series
mounting the male mounts the female a
few pelvic thrusts he sits back down the
male mounts the female few pelvic
thrusts sits back down
this goes on for hours before he
ejaculates so he could he could get a
bit distracted other females might
solicit him for sex he can get a bit
tired and if he's not mounting the
female at the pace that she wants him to
mount then she will perform a mount on
him she will either mount prompt him or
she will mount him and perform pelvic
thrusts against him sometimes while he
masturbates and then this seems to sort
of reset his brain he's like oh yeah I'm
with you he swings around behind her and
stars mounting again so from from a
female's perspective that female male
mounting looks like it's an adaptation
it's a way that females can control male
movement and get the male that they want
to inseminate them to do what he has to
do once you have that you have a system
where females are capable of mounting
but why would the why would that female
mounting then spill over so to speak
into a female female context when I've
just told you there's no social function
to that behavior well in order to
understand why that adaptive behavior
might spill over into a female female
context you have to think then start
thinking about the behavior from
approximate perspective and during the
vast majority of these mouths females
are stimulating their clitoris they do
so either by rubbing their clitoris
against their partners or by stimulating
their clitoris with their tails
during the mounts so at that point in
the evolution of the species we have
females that can mount we have females
that derive immediate sexual reward from
mounting and then if they can do that
with a male they can just as easily do
it with a female and the
or spills over so to speak as an
evolutionary by-product into a female
female context from none of them are
exclusively lesbian
none of them are known I think that so
your question was how does that how does
that relate to humans well I think that
you know we can often think about is
male homosexuality and adaptation maybe
we should be thinking about it more like
we think about the Japanese macaques
maybe it's not an adaptation maybe it's
a byproduct of something else and the
best data to date suggests that maybe
it's a byproduct of elevated fecundity
in the female kin of male homosexuals so
let me explain that the idea the idea is
that there are genes for male Andra
philia or there are genes for Andrew
philia being attracted to adult males if
you pass these genes on to your son you
produce a male homosexual who's not
going to reproduce if you pass these
genes on to your daughters you produce
females that are more fecund so the
basic prediction that one derives from
this hypothesis is that the female kin
of male homosexuals should be morphicon
they should be having more babies and in
the various populations where this has
been studied to date in Italy and in
England and in Samoa we found that this
is indeed the case if categories of
female kin such as the mothers of 15a we
compared them to the mothers of straight
men in Samoa we found multiple times now
with different studies that the mothers
of fathe fina are more fecund than the
mothers of straight guys you do the
research in Italy with gay guys and
straight guys they're the ants the
maternal aunts the mothers and the
maternal grandmother's of gay guys are
all more fecund they're having more
babies than the equivalent in straight
guys so maybe the male homosexuality in
humans is a byproduct of selection for
these genes
increase fecundity in their female kin
that's a complicated answer to your
question I know but but it's all about
thinking outside the box and thinking
well it wasn't an adaptation in Japanese
macaques it looks more like it's a
byproduct of an adaptation which
immediately gets more complicated and it
doesn't look like it's an adaptation in
humans maybe it's a byproduct of an
adaptation and whenever you start
talking about byproducts of adaptations
the the narrative so to speak gets a lot
more complicated in that question of how
the animal work applies to humans I mean
it's always a question your mind so you
know for like 25 30 years I've been
studying sex differences in the
structure of the brain of animals where
you know some areas are masculine in
other areas or in some areas the the
brain regions larger in males and
females and in other areas it's the
other way around and in the animal
models I can make each animal's brain as
masculine or feminine as I want simply
by controlling the exposure to
testosterone right usually I have to
expose them to testosterone early in
life and that will mask on eyes their
brains but you know for most of my
career I mean I as I told you I was
studying at because I want to know how
to control behavior I was very skeptical
about whether any of that was that
working in humans you know I spent all
day yesterday that Bronx Zoo and as a
biologist you're walking around you see
sex everywhere right you see sex
differences everywhere but and you see
how compelling it is but on the other
hand all the individuals that were
engaging in higher-order symbolic
communication were on my side the glass
right there were the ones who are
talking to each other you know telling
each other you know don't do that or do
that and and so you really wonder as jim
says these enormous brains between our
ears you know to what extent does all
that you know sort of override any
biological influences and I think for me
at least personally the surprise has
been that you can't find evidence of
biological influences too it's just not
going to be but as you say it's not
going to be that hormone level alone
makes a difference
from one of the players and it's having
an influence and sometimes when we're
lucky we can see evidence for that
influence but it's you know it's one
part of the puzzle I think people are
very drawn to the idea of those there
being a connection I think and you know
any or all of you read the children's
book that was written about the gay
penguins in the Central Park Zoo and
tango makes three penguins who in fact
were at the Central Park Zoo and who
then when two male penguins settled a
nest together as the other penguins had
eggs to take care of as penguin couples
they didn't and they eventually found a
rock and put it in their little nest and
took care of it and the zookeeper
ultimately swapped out the rock and gave
them a little baby penguin of whom they
were the doting parents one of them
subsequently the two parent penguins ran
off with a female penguin but that did
not that unfortunate episode was not in
the children's book now detention but I
think there is some kind of longing to
think that there is a purity of
explanation available and there
certainly is instantly an impulse when
you talk about the cross fostering of
sheep and goats to think oh wow that
symmetry things just like you know my
cousin Susan who did this crazy thing
and I think part of what's both
fascinating and frustrating about this
work is that there are so many
fascinating studies and so many
fascinating insights and it's so
difficult to put them together into a
single coherent constellation so you're
all doing amazing work it's all
fascinating it's all incredible and I
don't know how it can be assembled or
whether it can be assembled one
assemblage comes with the idea that when
you look at the evolution of the brain
from amphibians on up you see common
structure and even though the brains may
be smaller or larger the common at least
subcortical structuring is identical now
it turns out that's very important for
sexual behavior
for processing stimuli so a good example
is clitoral stimulation as you were
referring to with the Japanese macaques
where is it represented in the brain so
very commissar across the river and at
Rutgers has done brain imaging studies
looking at women who were getting
clitoral stimulation to orgasm and he
finds a distinct regions of the brain
that are activated by the stimulation
alone and by the stimulation when it
produces orgasm there are added areas
that get activated turns out when I'm
giving clitoral stimulation to my female
rats it's the same areas that are
activated right and when I see that I am
struck by the fact that nature mother
nature loves it keeper if it works she
doesn't share some putts with it it's
gonna work it's gonna work in them in a
macaque it's gonna work in a rat it's
gonna work in a human and I'm struck by
the fact that I can stimulate other
areas of the female and not get that so
it's really specific to her clitoris and
then I'm struck by the fact that well if
I take out her ovaries so I'm removing
the hormonal influences the clitoral
stimulation is still desired by the
female rat right who will come to my
port graduate student as she's moving
her arm out of the cage and grab it by
her teeth and pull her arm back in
because she's got she's got the magic
little paintbrush right so I look at
this and I said well that's that's
fabulous like why would that happen is
there a human counterpart to that well
sure there is postmenopausal women who
are not taking hormone replacements
still masturbate so what is that it's a
homology and it means that really were
all the same creatures but we have a
massive cortex like you were saying that
allows us to give language and meaning
to it that perhaps animals don't do well
think you've language and meaning to it
but also to have a context in which
there's a particular role that's
assigned in Samoan society which is
different from the role in New York
today which is different from Utah today
or from England in 1850 what do you make
as the art Okun woman
of this idea of the relationship between
what you have observed in the female
sexuality and the impulse toward
reproduction which kind of popular
culture would propose that female
sexuality is much more tightly linked to
reproduction and less random than male
sexuality well I think that one of the
things that I've been struck by is how
divergent at least what I've been
looking at with with sexual arousal has
been from what would be that expected
pattern that would be associated with
reproduction I don't think anybody would
have expected that heterosexual women
would be the ones who are getting turned
on by both women and men you know what I
won't understand the proximal mechanisms
for those kinds of patterns of arousal
so I I think that you know coming back
to this idea of sort of re-examining and
rethinking the models that have been
informing the way that we've been
studying this you know a lot of what
we've been talking about as the token
female I need to you know talk about
female sexual minorities a bit more so I
a lot of the research that we've been
talking about on sexual orientation has
primarily been done looking at male
sexuality you know there's there there's
a few studies here and there that have
looked at what's happening in lesbian
women but really this is an uncharted
frontier and you know to come back to
something that the Jim was talking about
the the cross-fostering study I was
hoping you would take it talk about what
happens with the female sheep and goats
but so so here we have the cross
Foster's males who are preferentially
going to that which raised them and then
what happens with the the females and
well they can go either way so the same
mechanisms at least in these animals
don't seem to be working and so I'm at
I'm in the position and the researchers
who are you know sort of bold enough to
get into this where we're not standing
on the shoulders of giants
to try to build a model of understanding
female sexuality that can someway be
informed by what we've learned about
about men but to also understand the
uniqueness of female sexuality and the
role of reproduction you know we do
different stuff women and men are
different and we have to begin to
incorporate that and understand that
from the female perspective right we're
getting close to the end but you bring
up a question which is actually implied
in a lot of the other research here
which is are women and men different and
if women and men are different to what
extent do what the behaviors that I
outside of normative heterosexuality
represent people acting according to the
norms of another gender which is much of
what you're describing in Samoa for
example and to what extent is
homosexuality bisexuality paraphilias
whatever they may be to what extent are
those things actually typical of
someone's biological gender but
represent another way of expressing that
gender rather than a way of
accommodating the standards of the other
gender we have five minutes I mean one
of the things that that we were
discussing among ourselves earlier today
is how gay men in a way present quite a
mixed picture at least in our society
and that they you might consider them
feminine in some ways in terms of who
they are attracted to but on the other
hand or in terms of mental rotations
where men tend to be better at that than
women and and in terms of aggression
we're ten men tend to be more aggressive
than women and in those ways gay men are
more like women but on the other hand
for the really big sex differences in
behavior those are in things like
interest in visual pornography or
interest in multiple partners or
interest in young partners are
interested in physically attractive
partners in all those ways gay men seem
as masculine as straight men and so I
think one of the puzzles that we have to
deal with is asking ourselves you know
how how they can present this mosaic
pattern which I think suggests that it's
not going to be a simple answer
how's that for two men
I mean to say later if Plato in the
Republic suggests that actually the men
who are attracted to other men are the
most masculine of all because they are
in a realm of higher masculinity than
the men who are actually drawn to the
feminine and are in from two women so
you've got some history behind you on
this one absolutely I think you know you
asked earlier about tying it all
together and I think if there's one way
we can serve higher research programs
together it's that we're all interested
in understanding the diversity of
sexuality but in an in as objective and
in as evidence-based a manner as
possible we're interested in
understanding the diversity of sexuality
and how its organized on its own terms
rather than how we would like the world
to be and that being said you know the
science we're doing is attempting to
accurately describe the world that
doesn't necessarily give us any lessons
about the kinds of societies and
communities we want to live in that
those those kinds of answers have to
come from from other realms of
investigation yeah and I would I mean
picking up on that point I would say
that the diversity that I've seen in
rats lowly little stupid cute cuddly
rats with tails that look like snakes
the people you know want to exterminate
the diversity and there's in in what
they're capable of learning sexually and
what they're capable of doing sexually
as far as I'm concerned they don't live
in a culture that I understand but they
certainly live in the same kind of
genetic diversity and behavioral
diversity that I would expect of any
species and I think that gives them an
edge I think gives all of us an edge
because the asteroid hits the people
that got the differences the people that
can you know sort of deal with that are
the ones that are going to survive the
ones that do the same old same old
aren't so you want diversity you don't
want sameness you want difference and I
think we need to I look at my rats I say
embrace the difference I look at people
I said well this is why
we maybe can survive that asteroid and
probably survive the things that
dinosaurs just couldn't with their
brains a sizeable walnut and their
limited sexual attractions any of you
who are attracted to woolly mammoths
know that this has been a problem I
won't comment a one of the one of the
key events and through the development
of my career and the interest in getting
into studying sexual orientation and
particularly focusing on gender
differences in sexuality had to do with
working in a clinic which was aimed at
dealing with forensic ly relevant
problematic sexualities like pedophilia
and and one of the big questions that
that was in my mind I was an
undergraduate at the time I was doing a
research assistant work was that we were
not seeing women why weren't we seeing
women and why weren't we seeing the
range of a typical or you know
paraphilic sexual preferences expressed
among women and and this for me became a
really sort of central driving force of
how do you explain that gender
difference and and so you know
responding to a little bit of what you
tossed in there yes I absolutely do
think that there are these gender
differences and how sexualities unfold
and manifest we don't understand why yet
but you know we're working on it I think
I'll just close and because unbeknownst
to all of you we have a little clock
here which is telling us exactly where
we are in the process but by saying that
to me it's it's incredibly interesting
altogether to see the things that people
want I'm struck over and over again by
the kinds of power that appeal to some
people the kinds of strengths that
appeal to other people the material
things that appeal to people I had that
moment in having small children I have a
son who's now just over two years old
and I thought why is it that he so much
wants that toy and doesn't have any
interest in that toy not because of the
way the toys were gendered which is
another whole conversation but just in
general the specificity of his wishes
from a very early stage not only for
other people but for a particular blank
over another blanket or a particular
song over another song and it then left
me to think you know why do I actually
like I don't know Chippendale furniture
better than IKEA give him the choice
where does any of it come from why does
one have this thing and I feel as though
while the investigation is already broad
enough insofar as it applies to
sexuality but ultimately the heart of
all of this work is to understand what
longing is about in what longing is for
and how incredibly broadly longing can
operate in all of us for a whole variety
of things and people and experiences and
how that longing is actually the essence
really of our humanity so on that note I
thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]